it's about a character named science
theology stick around
this show is sponsored by betterhelp it
is so easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and never
to take a moment to think about what you
need from yourself therapy can give you
the tools to find more balance in your
life so you can keep supporting others
without leaving yourself behind so key
find more balance with Better Health
visit betterhelp.com DPT to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash d p t do it today hey
town he's hooking another episode of
dumb people time
yes of course you're an alderman you're
Scott Alderman dude you hold a special
place you just got your green card what
was it what special place well I would
say probably like 13 years ago or so you
said to these two dudes come do a
podcast over where I'm doing mine back
on a poker table in Hollywood yeah
that's right we it almost was we were
the sister podcast to Comedy
you guys were the first show that we
wanted to come over and then I started
interning at UCB and said do you guys
ever do interns at Earwolf and you said
talk to Jeff you're from Chicago he's
gonna like that and then
you're gonna like that you were like
we're like hey Jeff Weller can I usually
meet here before Comedy Bang Bang so you
should talk to him and I talked to Jeff
and then I helped build the microwave
stand at Earwolf as an intern and
started working Legacy I hope it's still
there and then uh started working with
these guys because of that yeah you are
uh
yes I I cannot take any uh credit for
your success but I I'm glad that you
still remember
I know you've created people in your day
but I think the creation of yes I
didn't even have to have sex to do it oh
you didn't have to you guys just
mind-melded that baby it was scientific
it really was and you know what you did
a beautiful well you know this you know
the stream here it's just you know the
story world's still dumb that's the good
news since we were way better it might
even be Dumber it might even be done and
I've got the first story since you just
do it all right here we go here's the
headline okay uh this is sent in by the
way by Zach at zdot underscore MKE
Milwaukee
or Mike that's that airport code okay
and K is the m-k-e MKE yep man charged
with burglarizing Brewers Clubhouse
following game in September
wait so he hung around till after the
game let's get into it I mean I know
you're a big sports fan
the Brewers are a
let's start with the fact that the name
of the baseball team involves brewing
beer yeah yeah so we're in a culture of
alcohol you're asking for something
crazy to happen I know this because of a
bit I do about Wisconsin I'm pretty sure
I remember it correctly of the 50 50
most drunkest counties in the United
States 39 of them are in Wisconsin and
nine of the top ten are in Wisconsin you
know you can't buy I I lived there which
was very weird because I was just in
Wisconsin on tour and I said this is the
first time I've ever been in Wisconsin
and someone raised around and said you
lived here for a while that's how drunk
you were Scott so I lived in Milwaukee
but you could not buy alcohol after uh
it was like seven or nine yeah there's
different yeah so they stocked up like
three even Milwaukee as a city is like
we gotta cut these people off right
right we need it like we know we know
what you're capable of you gotta cut
them off even animals well good things
for people in Wisconsin and a lot of
them are believe they believe in
stockpiling so also like the idea that
like we're Brewers fans the team no we
just like the people who Brew the beer
but this dude do you think the logic
here is game's over yeah whatever they
left in The Dugout they obviously don't
want that's right Dave's over my game's
just beginning it's so much more than
that I'm just gonna take it away just
wanna drink it all right after passing
out in the bushes outside of American
Family field he's not even at the game
well I mean he is well he may have been
at the game but he might have either
been to the game never made it in I mean
do you is this like the Homer Simpson
meme where he just disappears yeah
there's probably more of a fall into the
bushes okay but I love that that's my
favorite they had to name the stadium
American Family field just to try to
encourage less drinking cool guys
awesome family field I talk about this
on stage two do you know what the legal
drinking age is in the state of
Wisconsin 15 with a parent it is 14
years old
no you can drink with a legal guardian
which means it doesn't even have to be
your parent it can be the uncle nobody
trusts your boy scout leader you could
be your you could be um
I've seen it firsthand you could be on a
lake trip with your friend like you're
both 14 years old and they're as long as
their parents are in the bar you can
drink you can go up to that bar and
order whatever you want isn't this wild
it's insane America this is Wisconsin
shouldn't things be legal if people want
to do it I don't know I guess here's
what it is okay after passing out on the
bushes outside of American Family field
a man allegedly made his way into the
Milwaukee Brewers Clubhouse how do you
do that yeah this is the interesting
part yeah he stole Electronics a credit
card team memorabilia and other
merchandise according to the charges
filed by from The Dugout
the clubhouse if you make your way into
the clubhouse you should be able to keep
everything you take yeah it should be
like a supermarket Suite he made his way
people say we don't make things in
America he made I hope when the cops
came in and go what are you doing buddy
he's like making my way making my way
it actually picked very little none of
these doors are locked okay Justin
blodorn oh that's great Justin bloated
he's a real [__] which by the way is
what you do when they give you an
alcohol breathalyzer put your mouth on
the blowdorn and give us a blow all
right that's what a lot of trekkies want
to do oh that is great
for the win his name is Michael Jordan
okay
he was charged with a felony any
burglary on December 14th so this
happened recently holiday season
according to the court records according
to the criminal complaint the man
attended the September 8th double header
never forget where you were on nine
eight
um between San Francisco Giants and the
Brewers with his roommate and his
roommate's father
so shocking this guy's not married you
got oh the game roommates and roommates
you got a lift home all right we're
going to say you okay to get home sure
yeah sure
of course just left him there roommate's
father that's a very not friend that's a
specific relationship exactly how do you
know this guy roommate's father
roommate's father should be the name of
a cologne or a sitcom
uh what do you what's that new scent
you're wearing it's called roommates
[__]
would you want a little distance in your
relationship uh the Milwaukee Journal
Sentinel reported that he drank at least
how many beers okay okay did Justin's
your neighborhood and Scott apparently
lived in Milwaukee yeah yeah don't ask
him I'm gonna guess one
you know what he might have said that I
had one beer one beer
this is after a double header this is
after a doubleheader and this is before
the pitch clock yeah
Games took a long time four and a half
hours what is like the intermission in
between yeah
no it's got to be more than that yeah
people stick around do you buy tickets
and you get to see both yes yes so what
do you do like it's probably only it can
it can't be like a three-hour
International
it's only an hour okay so we're talking
about four four hours for each game
eight or nine hours yeah nine hours how
many beers
I'm gonna go with the number of dresses
in my favorite film 27. yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna go 11 11 years he definitely
had like 20 20 beers but is this what I
mean this is what he said I think I mean
one of you is one beer off oh okay now
we all have the chance now to change it
by 21. 10 26 10. all right one of you is
right now okay
the answer we could have all gone the
wrong way one of you is two years now uh
everyone shot at your ham radio Justin
blodorn according to the Milwaukee
Journey Sentinel drank 10 beers
that's it ten I mean that's a lot it's
an obvious lie here it is Dan here it is
he's saying yeah but it really is it's
probably like 27. all right ten beers
woke up in the bushes and re-entered the
stadium by pulling a door until it
opened up so this is like January six
rules
yeah the capital yeah so how'd you get
in I pulled the door until it opened up
right hey should we fix that door over
there yeah No One's Gonna pin just like
then he's on just an unsupervised tour
that's right he's just lodorn then ended
up in the Brewers Clubhouse where he
began taking items within the locker
room according to the Milwaukee again
this is so much like January 6. you took
a piece of Nancy Pelosi's mail it was
weird uh this is what he took he was uh
a Brewers strength coach that's the
wrong
stated that he was missing a work
backpack a laptop two iPods
one for each year
that is by the way the dream to have a
work backpack and a home backpack
honey where's my where's my where's my
work back there you're wearing it I need
to watch the game where's my home
backpack not the gym one no where's my
fun backpack where's my travel backpack
it's by my work backpack nope that's my
home backpack what are you doing what
are we even do we need to organize the
back I need to find my two iPods I don't
want to use my bedroom back where's my
two iPods a Walkman a wife this guy's
insane this guy's from the 80s two pairs
of headphones a passport yeah if you're
gonna have two iPods and one Walkman
have three headphones
where is he going two pairs of
sunglasses passport is a person who
doesn't have a license a pass two pairs
of sunglasses someone's like going in
disguise a credit card and personal
notebooks and calendars from his office
calendars calendars well if he's got an
iPod he does not have an iCal yeah let's
be honest about this guy passport is to
go to Canada though right is it oh I bet
you're right yeah yeah that's a great
call that is a great logical call it's
got to go in the work it makes total
sense uh manager yeah we gotta go play
against Toronto next week yeah he needs
a passport uh Craig counsel also had a
jersey and shaving kit vanish from his
office that's how half of those things
make sense this makes the actual list
though like why is it set to he also had
this yeah shaving kit shaving that's a
good thing to steal when you're drunk
hey whose shaving kid is that it's Craig
counsels how can you prove it so far the
only thing that makes sense is the
Jersey Craig council's Jersey Council
Jersey and someone would be like you
just bought that didn't you no if that
was the only time I bet they'd let him
keep it yeah the Brewers the Brewers in
addition a Brewers equipment manager
said that a game-worn hat an autographed
baseball bat a 45-year anniversary 1982
Brewers wow and they played the
Cardinals signed bat a replica World
Series ring
and keys to the Arizona spring training
facility were all taken from this that's
unbelievable so we know where this guy's
going with his passport he might go to
Mexico and then come back up to Arizona
party in the Arizona facility detectives
eventually learned that two Brewers
game-issued jerseys were also taken from
the team Clubhouse along with a small
locker room bag full of baseballs and
pitching training devices there's so
much stuff this has been like four
sentences
he also took this stuff
carry right
when you're drunk
you don't know how much stuff you can
fit into a work bag oh my God true uh
following the burglary Blue Door
blow-dorn reportedly caught an Uber to
take him home along with the stolen
items the criminal complaint stated that
some of blue doors is the Uber driver
then an accessory to the crime yeah the
wheel man yeah that's right baby driver
that's a baby driver there he is uh
blood orange thefts were caught on
surveillance video inside the stadium
obviously yeah I know she was gonna be a
Cameron someone saw this guy walking
around oh yeah let's see what he takes
well we'll get it back we're at the
crime scene blood orange roommate called
police and told them that he had
returned home early on September 9th
with the duffel bag full of Brewers told
you not a friend with a roommate ratted
him yes surprise was the roommate's
father roommate's father because you're
never safe with the truth the majority
of the items were recovered at bloedorns
apart the majority of them
to the Arizona facility that's in the
Uber he's still in the Uber the Uber
driver am I gonna pay you but if you're
ever in Arizona if convicted how many
years
can he face in prison I mean well this
is they Max it out this isn't what
you're going to end up I know but just
20 years the number of dresses in my
favorite movie
I'm going to say uh 10 years in prison
all right if convicted you can face up
to 12 years and six months in prison 12
years and six months again just say 12
and a half years so you can face 12
years in prison period yeah
leave them alone how big of a fine we'll
get out of here okay and then and then
we'll guess his age oh all right well
let's do this I have 15K
I'm going to guess in thousands the
number of dresses in my favorites I love
it uh I'm gonna say 20 grand 20 grand
get your answers in Scott Ackerman is
close as twenty five thousand dollars
yeah definitely paid off how old
is this person how old is Justin blodorn
I mean if you don't say 27 I don't know
what you got a roommate he's going to a
double header you obviously didn't have
to work that day this is tough who is
this guy say you're now a parent look
this could happen in your life your kid
could get drunk fall in the bush she has
a roommate and his roommate still hangs
out with his father so well that's not
his relationship with his own dad though
but I mean I don't know how old his
roommate ratted on him Jay you wanna I
know you if if this were you and someone
else is reading the story you would want
this guy to be 62. of course but I know
that's not true I'm gonna guess
somewhere between 26 and
28.7 and I didn't think you were going
to go there I'm gonna say he's 31 years
old I'm going to say he's 21 years old
21 years old get your answers in okay
closest once again is Scott Ackerman 25
years old
what are you gonna spend it on what are
you gonna waste your money on by the way
you can sell all these memorabilia and
put a thousand and let it okay anyway I
love it join everyone down the bus when
we come back we're gonna find out about
uh the new book that Scott Ackerman is
somehow behind somehow he's behind me
what is this book that we're hearing
about tell you about all this other
stuff The Bookies behind let's take a
break we'll come back with more dumb
people town and Scott Ackerman right
after this
hey townies welcome back to the show uh
before we get into Story number two uh
and before we get into Scott ackerman's
book uh we have some comedy dates coming
up where you can come see us yes
um I don't know if this will be coming
or dropping before or after we're in
Minneapolis if it's before on
Minneapolis on uh May 18 19 20th will be
at the Acme Comedy Company which is one
of our favorite places to play great I
love this out right away pretty soon
yeah and then we got uh um we're doing
another night of our show tag it at uh
at The Comedy Store on June 14th that's
the belly room that sold out before uh
the night of which was so good I first
did comedy did you is that where you
first said playroom it's a wonderful
place to do comedy now I actually love
the room for this show tag it which I
don't know if you've ever heard this
show that we do but our comedian friends
do their sets while they're doing their
set Jay and I are off to the side
writing tags
if I'm in town I'm gonna come watch hey
Danny be on it yeah great I get it
uh all our dates are at superscars.com
Daniel what about you sir go to
danielvankirk.com Irene two and I have a
show every other Monday at the cat's
crawl you can uh come and see that and
then
um are we doing it this Monday
if this is before the eighth you bet
your ass you are all right as of today
yes you are doing it next Monday night
okay good to know yeah everything has
nothing to do no bearing on what's what
we're saying right here but there you go
right and then also uh check my dates
for stuff I'll be around this summer
database uh Scott I'll come in the new
book let's talk about it it is a book
completely about Dianetics is that
correct yeah you know the whole the
whole lore behind Diana you felt like it
was not written the correct way it's
called Scientology right yes
it's about a character named science
theology science
for real though because I haven't got my
hands on it is this essentially the
Bible of Comedy Bang Bang no it's okay
so it's Comedy Bang Bang the podcast the
book yeah and uh when the publisher
pitched it to me I kind of thought they
were like pitching like a handbook or
like bios and stuff like that or a
episode list yeah and that was really
interesting but no they wanted me to do
a thing which is more like the
characters on the show submitting pieces
for the book I love that so it's all of
the comedians who are on the show all
the time Paul F Tompkins Lily Sullivan
Andy Daly all these people Bobby
Moynihan all these people have written
uh pieces for the book and so it's like
it's their character as their character
so it's sort of like a collection of
posters and games and like weird uh
business cards and and lists and all
sorts and this does it if I remember
correctly
um isn't it you're doing a really fun
thing up top where it's like the forward
to the forward the rebuttal of the
prologues there's the forward is by
lin-manuel Miranda rebuttal to the
forward by Weird Al Yankovic basically
just makes fun of lin-manuel I love it
and the mistakes he made that's great uh
and then uh forward to the preface
preface to the forward like all the
I mean it's it's wonderful because
you're like if Comedy Bang Bang did a
book that's it weirdly enough yeah how
would we do this and how would it be and
if you love the TV show and you love the
podcast where do people go together
people can get it anywhere uh Amazon
Barnes Noble or you know anywhere you
get books I do believe it's pronounced
Amazon sorry
Amazon uh that is their theme song
what's best where's the best place you
want people compare to me okay yeah get
it wherever you want get it where you
want are you doing any dates this year
uh no I just did some for the book uh to
open and I'm probably gonna take the
rest of the year off uh but who knows
okay those are great shows when you guys
do it phenomenal and fun shows and of
course listen to podcasts subscribe to
it enjoy it podcast is every week in
cbbworld.com is out there which is the
subscriber patreon where people can sort
of like if you're just listening to
Comedy Bang Bang You're not getting all
the extra stuff which is like all the
characters have their own shows and also
I love it right fantastic on our patreon
too we should mention that to our fans
yes we have a patreon as well we can do
extra stuff it is a competition
is in a conversation with the CBB right
now we're in second uh this is called
CBD world it's a very different thing no
it's uh you get the patreon it's we had
extra stories and extra things and extra
content five bucks you get more of it
yeah are we ready for my story I'm so
excited my story was sent in by our good
friend Carlene McDermott she sends a lot
in at Carlene fantastic fantastic uh
handle you ready for this yeah and this
is one of those stories it's one of
those Reddit stories where we have to
decide who is against the [__] like
who along the way are we and I'll check
in with you periodically and say all
right Scott whose side are you on now
and then it's more So for anybody who
doesn't know and Reddit there's a thread
where people tell their own story with
the big questions
there are times they usually are they
yes the fun thing is is when it starts
[__] here it starts out when they
definitely are and then by the end
you're like well maybe you aren't I like
when it changes
uh all right all right hit it groom
threatens to cancel wedding
oh yeah whose side are we on now well I
don't know yet after Brides suggests
their dogs marry each other
okay she's nuts but uh so far during the
wedding she suggests this uh either way
well before the wedding if you consider
your dog your child then she wants a
brother and Stepbrother and stepson hang
on a second which is legally fine
because it goes in so many directions a
groom claims he's now considering
calling off his wedding already
considering it come on come on
are We checking call me when the place
has been rebooked
all together after his so far he's the
[__] by the way because yeah I guess
it's a little money impressed when he's
just considering yes just considering it
it might be it might be the journalist
yeah who do you think wrote this I don't
know so far just based on that do you
think he is wondering if he's the
[__] or his father I think yes you
know I love that
and the roommate's father is going to be
giving the bride away
he's the [__] to me he considers her
his keep going ran foreign
a groom is now considering calling off
his wedding altogether after his fiancee
and her best friend revealed their plans
to quote marry their dogs to one another
at the actual ceremony so this is his
wife is saying hey when we get married I
want you know you know my friend Kelly
yeah
married too at that same ceremony look
that is wild also have the wedding you
want right you won't have a goddamn rent
for a wedding I don't care but both
people need to be into it a second or
red wedding he's just looking for a
reason
according to yeah he doesn't want to be
according to this exasperated man
somehow maybe he did write it this is I
mean this is the journalist by the way
he's like especially someone who wrote a
story a lot of opinion yeah exactly it's
like did the guy say I'm exasperated
then you can call him this is somebody
who wrote a story about a Reddit post
right according to this exasperated man
again exasperated man one of my favorite
Smith songs his bride to be just
exasperated mom
you're really good and her maid of honor
Abby have long planned to hold a quote
doggy wedding ceremony between their
dogs and their future husband's dogs
this is what the two best friends said
when we when you get married we're gonna
have a dog this makes sense if Abby's
getting married at the same it's like an
MGM double wedding you know at the end
of thousand dollars or whatever right
where it's like okay Abby is getting
married and her best friend but they're
just getting married and then we're
gonna marry the dog the dog too then
it's cute but that's the fine it doesn't
sound like Abby is close to getting
married no so okay well she's close to
someone who is getting married do it at
the rehearsal dinner you really want to
do that you really want to deal with
this is such a great day of your own
he's also a dog priest you got to bring
this dog priest in and deal with who's
the dog this is not a priest that is a
dog a human priest who just deals with
who officiates
but they're dressed like a Saint Bernard
here's dog confessions
dog fashions
all right I have planned to have blood
dog away all right as he doesn't have
any dogs of his own however uh not being
much of a quote dog person himself I
can't believe that wasn't enough yeah
why is he getting married to this woman
anyway she has a dog she's a dog the two
Pals meaning Abby and Jessica yeah okay
quickly began gushing about how cute it
would be to include both of their pets
in the upcoming wedding Abby's kind of
stepping in here a little too far in my
opinion Abby this isn't your wedding you
can't now bring your dog into their
wedding I would be mad as a groom I
would be mad I would be mad this isn't
it or I would hold this is why this
guy's an idiot marriage is all about
who's holding the capital so okay let
her have the dog wedding and then you go
you know this is about who's holding the
capital what a romantic you are just yes
Jason's in succession so listen to this
who has the upper hand so this isn't his
sort of thing at all but he and me
listen to the guy he initially agreed to
keep Jessica happy presuming she just
want the dogs there with them at the
altar I think a lot of people my dog was
was led up to our father on the wedding
and then sacrifice
that was very odd I I don't know why you
did execution oh my God we're gonna get
letters on that unfortunately it soon
emerged Abby and Jessica wanted a
full-blown wedding ceremony for their
pooches
with entire parts of the reception
dedicated to their pets friendship so
now I'm feeling like Jessica's just
getting married so she can have a
wedding so they can finally have the
wedding they really want which is
between us also the dogs have not
consented to this 100 now yeah maybe
maybe the dogs you want to marry maybe
that's not this dog maybe they want a
civil union they don't want to be tied
down by law exactly talking they don't
even want a big one these dogs are going
to get in annulled in a week anyway so
this is such a such a a exercise in
futility well I think Jessica and David
are going to as well
talking to Reddit where he goes by the
username you slash need he wrote superb
cookie
honey honey come to bed what are you
doing I'm letting strangers decide how I
feel about our relationship is that
weird so sorry I'm so sorry is that a
weird moment all right so the the Grim
I'm not going to give it a stage we'll
guess it
get like puppy pictures slideshow a cake
for them dog friendly favorite oh this
is what he wrote yeah dogs Vapor bags
because they want their friends and
their family to bring their dogs too
this is a goddamn dog run right here now
I told them no and then I already made
one compromise on the issue and I don't
want a bunch of dogs around for an
entire wedding and reception and if they
did that we'd have to find an all-new
venue probably no [__] no matter what
venue you get you're going to lose the
deposit yeah I reminded her that she was
near the limit of what she could
contribute towards our wedding funds
I got a tally going all right and I'd be
paying the rest and I don't want to pay
extra stuff for a bunch of dogs is what
he said they both said that this was
really important to them so I told
Jessica Point Blank he said it to her he
said Point Blank we can stick to what we
originally agreed to or she and Abby
could have their costly party see that
he didn't have to go he wants to throw
in how expensive it is that allows dogs
by themselves and we just get married at
the courthouse by ourselves so he's
trying to blow this whole thing up now
yeah exactly just get married to the
courthouse that's fine let me tell you
something let's do that instead because
you want to have the dog wedding photos
we you so you can have the dog house
we're gonna go to the courthouse that's
probably what I said well I can tell you
guys look you dead in the eyes and say
Abby did not take this well Point black
Abby did not take this well at all and
told Jessica you know what Abby told
Jessica he was being manipulative and
making ultimatums which he kind of is
yeah yeah but you're allowed to make
ultimatums
same yeah just you know if you do that
I'm going to blank right yes we he's
like I already gave in on this issue and
we could walk the dogs to the altar if
you want but like so we're not doing
it's not even mine I'm not saying
exactly what I say you're making an
ultimatum yeah right even asking her to
stay at hers until the groom pulls his
head out of his ass she's like Abby says
you go stay at my house until the this
guy pulls out Jessica also reportedly
feels that he's being selfish but simply
wants the wedding to be about them and
not Abby and her pets that's the thing
Abby's not part of this well Abby is
really interesting yourself in this
whole situation but you're but or
Jessica is going
to do not want to ask each of you I'm
going to start with you Jay and we'll
end with Scott here who do you whose
side are you on here because there's a
lot of stuff I'm on the groom side
you're on the groom so 100 on the groom
side why because he gave a little he
gave a little and it's not they don't
this this is like he doesn't want to be
on the experimental stage at dogchella
okay you know what I'm saying like he
wants to be on the main stage
his dogs are on the main actually the
craziest
Three Dog Night dog hologram followed by
Pitbulls all my dogs are there and then
the battle of the dogs
all right tell me please Dan who's
Society one here's the deal legitimately
they should be if they want to be
together right that's always the first
question in any relationship business or
personal this is you start out by going
do you want to keep doing this if both
people say yes they need they can find a
compromise just like the writers and the
streamers yes timely
um
[Laughter]
um I will go God damn
she's the [__] but he's not neither
of them are completely in the right he's
not budging he's not clean he's not
clean he's making it harder but she but
I literally think I would go is that the
wedding you want that is your ultimate
dream I would go that is not mine at all
so we can either do these two things
separately right or this is all you and
you just tell me when to show up but I
am not you tell her you say look you
will do this wedding and we'll do the
dog wedding it's fine I'm gonna go to
Burning Man by myself in like two weeks
and then who knows what happens yeah I
mean but I may come back I may not yeah
I might not come on but I'm excited
about our little dog wedding yeah but
have fun with the dog Scott who do you
whose side are you on here what's his
Reddit handle oh yeah something superb
a13 I'll be going to Vegas every Sunday
you slash need help superb cookie yeah
[__] him yeah all right he's the [__]
accordingly I think he needs to say he
they're has to be a serious accounting
of her relationship with Abby
you want to get married right or like go
for it yeah we all feel like I mean it's
a sin well
we know once she said everybody bring
their dogs this is you having a whole
lot you're not it isn't yours that's a
different event wedding anymore exactly
it's a dog run it's a yeah exactly I
mean this is where people say like
what's what are we gonna now when people
can let dogs marry each other dogs like
that's the pro that's the thing that
everybody's worried we haven't gotten to
those people I mean it's crazy what
about you man I think I I think the guy
was the guy gave a little bit by saying
like we can have the dogs walk up to the
Altar and I'm totally cool with that and
it can be Abby's dog and this dog and we
can be like but isn't that the other
deal too because if their dogs are
getting married and you're doing it in
your wedding Abby's the one holding her
dog so at some point all three of you
are up there no no so the so then the
priests should say this is what I would
give I Now Pronounce You and you to
that's it that's all you get and you two
dogs husbands everyone here except the
people that are already married like
make it really confusing everyone in the
room except for the people who are
already married or the people who are
dating and don't want that level anyone
who's been spayed and neutered you are
now pronounced you husband and wife you
know and then there you go but I feel
like he gave enough that she needs to
understand so she's got to give a little
bit is this a man and a woman dog that's
important that's a question Scott's
about to draw a hard line Wow gay dog
wow uh so there you go that's Story
number two down in the books Daniel do
you know what your story is about I
don't even remember okay so uh you could
do it all right so it's just about a
crazy family of four oh yeah I remember
crazy family of four these people are
we're gonna bring it on home and bring
it on home after this breaks God
argument's With Us he's got a new book
title of the book is if you want to go
get it Comedy Bang Bang the podcast the
book comedy May the podcast the book you
better go get it uh we'll be right back
stick around
hold up
hey guys this show is sponsored by
better help if you don't know what
better help does it's about therapy we
are therapy people my wife is a
therapist I've been in my own therapy
and I can't tell you how important it is
to have that outlet emotionally in your
life and it it's not just for you it's
for the people around you in your world
to have this objective outside force in
your life helping you examine who you
are and finding balance and gives you
that balance definitely as a person I've
done I've done therapy I'm in therapy
and having someone that you can talk to
I think is the most uh like beneficial
thing you can have in your life like a
professional that can help guide you
through just your people who say ups and
downs but really it's just like a
constant flow of life and how you manage
your health and feel good about yourself
better help Dan they make it so easy if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire and get matched with
a licensed therapist and here's what I
love you can switch there purpose at any
time for no additional charts you really
get to find the person who's right oh
yeah for more balance you got to find it
go to betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
DPT today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash DPT these guys are
amazing
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show we are
back uh Daniel Van Kirk today buddy sent
in by Megan Laskowski at soymates for
Eva or Eva I'm not sure here's the
headline
family of four all wielding knives stab
each other in Wild fight now at least
it's fair I mean yeah right I'm a family
of four so yeah so can you imagine if
everybody walking around your house just
had a knife I mean this is why you get a
suite when you go on the road on the
hotel how does it get to this point
right how does it get to that everyone
has a knife to the other person's throat
is it like one of those no no no start
with someone saying like hey I have a
knife the other person going that's not
a knife
it is the Dundee family
Paul Hogan
four family members a mother father
brother and sister were all stabbed
during a fight at their Texas Home on
Brandon I mean it is open carry of
knives in Texas Deputy with the Harris
County I believe that's where Houston is
Harris County Sheriff's Office responded
to a call around 10 50 p.m it feels too
early and too late a knife
10 50. this is what are we watching on
TV time most families by the way are
either asleep or they're going to still
they're still Wide Awake yeah and this
is still in the good time like we
haven't yeah exactly like like my family
we're all asleep at this time right but
then the people who stay up late this is
that everyone's they're fine
we're cleaning up dinner at 10 50. yes
exactly looks like someone brought a
knife to a knife fight they said to each
other
these people have knives so do you if
everyone has a knife I wonder if one
person didn't it was like hold on hold
on hold on
you better get her let your sister get
her knife she's had a that's a butter
knife honey what are you doing we all
have sharp ones they responded to the
call around 10 50 p.m on July 24th about
a family disturbance at a home on
Regional Parks
or a neighbor it's like they're at it
again no you know what they're foreign
exchange student yes who was like oh my
god oh Jesus I can't believe I came from
Croatia right also can you imagine that
call uh person with a knife how many all
of them all of them yeah we all do uh
Regional Regional Park Drive about 16
miles north of downtown Houston that's
probably like somewhere around Conroe I
know my area maybe the woodlands uh
Sheriff Ed Gonzalez is sending a tweet
the fight started between two adult
siblings so that's how it starts who are
brother and a sister the brother came
home that night intoxicated of course
and armed he and his sister got into a
heated argument which turned physical he
was a he Astros are cheating no they're
not well he was disarmed during the
struggle Gonzalez said and the mother
and father stepped in attempting to
break things up hey hey hey hey hey like
with knives so no one has knives at this
point because
he was disarmed he was disarmed so no
one has a knife I'm just tracking knife
so the so no one has a knife mother and
father step in to to deal with their
adult children right okay got it you're
like I'm so happy I don't have to break
up fights between you anymore you guys
are adults or adults now and also it's
in quote break things up which means
later when the cops got here they're
holding knives be like we're trying to
break it up right but you're now making
it worse but the violence only escalated
and each family member grabbed a knife
as the night went on or fight went on
both actually the night and the night
and the fight when deputies arrived at
the home they found all four members of
the family had been stabbed oh my God I
know bye did did everyone get one in or
did like one guy stab three and everyone
else did I heard her on the Orient
Express to the other person
don't even know
yeah I mean huh I guess you could get a
forensic person to be like well yours is
a Cutco knife and yours
yeah Scott you called it really everyone
survived Gonzalez added sure the brother
Manuel Alfredo Gutierrez was arrested he
did three charges of aggravated assault
he must have stabbed everybody and
himself
no because he only got three charges
right so someone else got him yeah you
can you get charged for stabbing
yourself yeah
you probably can three charges we'll get
out of here in this Dan I want there to
be a black eyed peace song about this
a knife fight yeah that's pretty good uh
all right well here we'll leave it real
quick how old do you think Manny
Gutierrez is no man who's been three
counts of stabbing he came home from
home drunk he started this thing he came
home drunk him and his sister I assume
all they both live still with his
parents adults living everyone grabbed a
knife which means they either had one or
they're hidden around the house get one
I'm gonna take a stab in the dark okay
at scar Brothers I'm gonna say hey 21
years old okay oh he's freshly minted I
have a feeling I know 21 year old is
gonna go with this but if he's drunk you
also got a factor and he's drunk and
getting home at 10 50. that's when the
call I have 21.
I'm gonna go with probably the amount of
dresses in my favorite film yeah when I
see it twice and I'm going to say 54.
so you're saying the parents are like 70
yeah eight and okay these adult children
them being 78 makes me think they
challenged him stab me [__]
let's go I'm ready I bleed air these
days uh that's so funny I'm gonna say
33. okay
Manny alfredo
Gutierrez Gutierrez yes also Scott
thanks for coming by today thank you
Scott great to see you everybody should
go how many Bang Bang the podcast the
book pick it up okay he is
25 years old
25 year olds out there
yeah 25 on a lot of these yeah there you
go guys that is the show thank you Scott
Ackerman we love you buddy
we gotta get back to work guys
stick around make a sound there's more
to people town
[Music]